好,我们今天要来聊一个很酷的主题
我们要来拆解一位顶尖操盘手的制胜系统
这位操盘手他每个月的交易量是高达数十亿的
你可能会觉得,哇,他一定是有什么神准的预测能力吧
但,诶,事实上哦,他的秘诀可能跟你想得完完全全相反
我们直接切入重点
你想想看哦
如果我跟你说
在市场上要能够持续赚钱的关键
其实不是去追求每一次都看对
而是要学会怎么样犯错
而且是错得更快
错得更小
你觉得怎么样
这个听起来有点矛盾的想法
其实正是一位顶尖交易员
他整个哲学的核心
也是我们今天要来好好剖析的重点
好
那我们就先从第一部分开始
顶尖交易员的秘密
我们要来看看
一位市场大师的脑袋里
到底在想些什么
这位交易员之所以能够驾驭
这么庞大的资金
跟你说
他靠的真的不是什么
预测未来的水晶球
而是一头极度强调纪律
还有快速反应的系统
你看
他整个策略的核心
就建立在一个
你可能觉得很简单
但其实超关键的信念上
那就是
市场是根本没办法预测的
就是因为他彻底接受了这件事
所以他完全放弃了那种想要猜头摸底的白日梦
也因为这样
他跟绝大多数的交易者就走上了完全不同的路
再来我们看到第二部分
这个系统的基础可以说是疯狂等级的纪律
它成功的根基并不是什么神奇的指标或战术而是那些在交易之前就已经完成的99%的准备工作那是一种对自我优化跟心理强度
近乎偏执的追求
哇 超过十个小时
你没看错
他每天就是花这么多时间在研究
在盯盘 在准备
这Commandment不是开玩笑的
投入到什么程度
他甚至因为用眼过度
搞到视网膜都受损了
这就给你看他对这件事有多么
可以说是近乎疯狂的执着
你想想看
在市场上
到底有多少人会真的很严格的
去复盘自己的每一笔交易
说真的
可能连1%都不到
但他呢
他就是那稀有的1%
他每天都会记录反省自己的操作
目标超简单也超难
就是确保同样的错误
绝对不会再犯第二次
这就跟交易圈里
常讲的一句话很像
对吧
新手才在问技巧
高手都在练心态
他深深相信
想要长期成功
关键绝对是在于
锻炼出一颗强大的心脏
而不是去外面到处
搅那个根本不存在的交易圣杯
OK
打好了纪律这个地基之后
我们来看第三部分
也就是它的蓝图控制亏损
焦点就从心态转移到更具体的层面了
那就是用非常严格的数学方法来做风险管理
我们来看看它是怎么做的
好
这边我们就要聊到一个超重要的观念
就是赚赔比
讲白话一点就是
你愿意冒多少风险去换取潜在的利润
你冒一块钱的风险会期望能赚回多少钱对于这个问题这位交易员有非常独到的看法他怎么看这个赚赔比呢他把它想成一个分数
分子就是你能赚多少钱这件事
老实说是市场给的
你根本控制不了
但分母呢
分母是你会赔多少钱
这就完全完全是你能自己决定的
所以啦
他所有的精力
就只专注在一件事情上
死死地把你能控制的那个分母
也就是你的亏损给锁住
那为了做到这一点
他有几条可以说是钢铁纪律的风控规则
首先进场前就要想好所有出场的路线
没有例外
再来如果部位真的太大了
那就要用期货这些东西来避险
然后最关键的一条来了
他绝对不留仓果眼
为什么
因为他超讨厌把自己的部位
暴露在任何他控制不了的风险底下
像是晚上美股大跌之类的
好 再来
我们就爬到金字塔的顶端了
第四部分
执行
让市场自己说话
这部分的核心
就不是去预测市场了
而是用小小的部位
去问市场现在的方向
然后去倾听他最及时的回馈
这就是他最有名的一招
叫做60秒试探策略
流程超简单
你听哦
第一步
先用你原本预计的10%的部位
丢进去试水温
第二步
马上看市场给你什么回馈
也就是看你账户是红字还是绿字
第三步也是最重要的
如果账户马上变富的
也就是赔钱了
那不管3721最慢
60秒内砍掉出场诶 这就带出他整个系统里最可以说是最反传统的一点了对他来讲唯一唯一重要的指标
就是你账户当下的损益
什么复杂的技术分析
他可能都不看
他就只相信最直接最诚实的回馈
我的部位现在是赚钱还是赔钱
就这么简单
所以你看他的逻辑其实超清楚的
如果我试着做多
啪被停损了
好
那我反手做空
结果啪又被停损了
这说明什么
这不就代表现在市场根本是盘整没有方向吗
那在这种时候
最聪明的做法是什么
就是什么都不要做
停止交易
把钱收回来
等下一个机会
就这样
好
讲了这么多
最后一部分
我们把前面所有东西串起来
把它变成一个很清楚的至圣金字塔
这样你也可以思考怎么建立自己的系统
你看这就是这位顶尖交易员的系统金字塔
最下面最稳固的地基是什么
是疯狂的纪律跟自我检讨
往上一层呢
是严谨的数学风控
一直到最上面那一小块
才是我们一般人最爱讨论的
那些灵活的交易战术
这张图就完美的告诉我们一件事
战术真的只是冰箱一角
它必须要盖在上面那一大块纪律跟风控的基础上
才有可能成功
好 那在我们今天分析的最后
我也想留一个问题给你自己思考一下
回头看看你自己的交易策略
你觉得你是把自己当成一个市场的预测者
还是反应者呢
这个问题的答案呢 我跟你说
很可能会彻底改变你对交易的看法哦